hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so let's start
actually with the eternal law that's
where Thomas starts skin and this is
questions question 91 he asks whether
there's an eternal law and maternal
means what lasting forever right but if
you actually meet something beyond
forever if something exists in eternity
that means that it exists at all times
and places as a matter of fact even
before time began it would it would be
there and when you get down to it if we
have time as well what's the eternal law
ultimately it is God God is not
something different than the law or the
reason or the structure that he gives
some things so it's not like you know
God one day said other people are
screwing around too much you need to
make a walk I'm going to make a law and
it's going to stick for good as I'm God
it's not that kind of trouble one way
that this that's a sort of popular
conversions of how things take place in
Bible anywhere that's not Thomas things
they take place there's a sort of
structure within God's mind that rates
everything that understands everything
to the good which again for Thomas is
ultimately what God and that's there
before even in the world is created so
when the world is created
Thomas things that other things are kind
of built into it based on this well this
is a pretty lofty idea we don't actually
get to see the eternal gas such who gets
who actually fully understands you turn
a lot and it gets to see it all the time
who do you think not us
just God right well we can grasp part of
it we can't grasp the Thomas says we
can't grasp the totality of it he says
leave unless it in heaven they don't
actually see every single thing but you
know they're better off then those of us
who are struggling down here trying to
make sense of things so we can grasp
this in part and Thomas thinks that the
distinctive way in which we human beings
do this is through the natural law so
this is what is really proper to us
don't we have some sort of ends built
into the fabric of our distinctive way
of being Thomas is yes so that's where
we get to the natural law so let's look
at this question after all that long
description whether there is a natural
law he says we can say that there is a
natural law in part because he says all
things are subject to divine providence
and they're ruled or measured by the
eternal law so all these things
particulate as they have these
respective inclinations do we have
inclinations do we have certain basic
drives and we're going to look at some
of these
yeah we do have certain basic drives do
we have certain distinctive at certain
things that human beings do that are
distinctive to us as a species
what would you say those are yeah like
upper cognitive abilities to be able to
reason
thank you yeah and you know to each do
some of that sort of leopard dolphin's
yeah to some extent and nothing like us
you know when when it fills a
supercomputer that maybe will start
going to take that seriously and say
dolphins which you know have it was
gigantic brain most of that brings
actually devoted to sonar turns out so
sonar was actually some language you can
build technology and communicate with
each other and build little society
maybe we take them more seriously that
they're they're sort of our rivals but
yet right our cognitive abilities what
else do we do that's to Stanford to us
that animals don't do except in cartoons
yeah
yeah I mean the impulse do communicate
each other but their range of
communication as much more limited than
our essence made only animal actually
gasps about language now animals aren't
bilingual you sound like an animal still
you know and sound like a dog says I
need to learn with those cats or saying
I think they're talking about me I
better learn some cat language it's just
a pant it doesn't it wouldn't occur to
them so language is a key thing what
else are there other things that we do
that are really distinctive Liam these
are great things the Tomas would love to
hear language rationality cognitive
abilities but are there other things
that set us apart that sometimes
interesting to think about those two I
think you start I actually brought this
up in a lecture I gave up at the
culinary earlier this week we're the
only animal that cooks I mean there are
so many animals that do modify their
food in certain ways so that they can
take in flies for example do their
digestion actually large for outside of
their body paragraphs frankly speaking
you know what they're doing is kind of
cooking the food but they're not
actually like getting up you know
pottery can and slicing things off of
mixing
together and say how can I make this
taste better we do that's distinctive
human behavior I guess you could ask you
to teach it you know chimpanzee to cook
I suppose and uh maybe they could get a
taste for certain things
ginger and that's that's us
what else there are other things just
totally distinctly
well not like things like going to
getting their awareness and that yeah
what's the mimicking okay that's a lot
of stuff right yeah going to school this
ties into those cognitive abilities we
have to develop those and that's made
possible because of speech for going to
school getting married I mean there are
animals that do made for life but they
don't have a ceremony for that do that
with this ring I thee Wed my beautiful
Mockingbird why
they don't do that yeah no silly
clothing ourselves yeah let's go yeah
can you can you turn the animals on to
that sort of thing yeah I mean you could
you could get a the chimpanzee and
they're very curious and they might like
it dressed on but they don't actually do
that in the wild do they we actually
impose it on a lot of animals that don't
like it like cats and dogs cats and dogs
don't really like being dressed up we
may can do it anyway especially the kids
never used to shove my dog into a pair
of shorts was the third than these that
so have to said any like chitosan living
traditions yes we have culture and again
you know if we look at the higher apes
they do have bands certain things will
cast on and become kind of traditions
book but I mean that's integral toys and
humans have been doing that for very
long time yes religion you don't find
animals let's say we take very sort of
the early types of religion you know
involving say some sort of cult with
sacrifices and as you know statue that's
supposed to represent some sort of deity
you don't find dog food you don't find
the lions who are you know the top of
their food chain you don't find dolphins
do you only fight even beings do only
human being to bury their dead with
things I mean most animals don't
we very weak or very odd early on bury
the dead with things that shows the you
know the existence of ELISA in the
afterlife like flowers or possessions
bury them in certain waves like an on
field position or in a laid out position
we we are symbolic creatures so that is
part of our our inclinations these are
things that that children play at these
are the things that are part of the
fabric of who we are it's not just our
higher cognitive abilities and those are
really important this is also these
things like passing on traditions like
cooking like religion you could probably
say we're also the only animal who truly
laughs who engages in things to try to
make each other laugh when hyenas make a
sound like laughter that's not actually
laughing even though the cartoons are
try to make it seem like that so that's
all in some way part of the facet of who
we are what we are the kind of beings so
the natural law is going to be connected
with and he says among all others the
rational creatures subject to divine
providence the eternal law in the most
excellent way how so we actually like
Thomas says partake of a share of
profits and again this is a this is a
theologically informed perspective right
Thomas sees us as being above the other
animals not just by having these greater
abilities but by being made part of the
part of the process having what we do
main part of the process sort of we get
to we get to be in the entry-level
positions in the divine bureaucracy
let's say right starting out male
or else you have to stare down but we
get to be parts of them how are we
problem both for itself
one one's own being and for others so
this is where for it is a sheer beige
for a reason whereby is a natural
inclination its proper and an act so our
natural inclinations are not just to
preserve our own lives or make ourselves
happy or something yeah there are also
provided we haven't gotten screwed up in
the process there also for others
they're also directed towards others
that's distinctively human to its
interested uh these are the nature films
and they found it on like water buffalos
they don't actually always abandon the
one that got you know chased by the
Lions and attack sometimes they'll come
in and they'll attack the Lions the same
but we do that sort of thing fairly
routinely so you have in the actual
bottom now what we want to do is we want
to clarify the other kids a lot of times
talks about the natural law tells us to
do certain things but it's very general
so it's not like law out there you know
like the law that govern us on speed on
robbed nine government speeding pretty
much everywhere else right if you speed
and you get quad you get a certain kind
of ticket it's all determined by a lot
to me they public if they're just
reserve the common good natural law is a
lot more general so then we get to what
he calls human
and this is the kind of law that were
used to thinking about the actual
determinant was in our society and these
can be more or less well made more or
less well put together I mean if any
have never run into a log is on Java
unfair
the people you know complain a lot whole
time I mean like laws like just created
by the government our law it's like a
rattly fire my government's human human
walk where you starting with that these
are laws actually created by some sort
of governing body I mean it doesn't
necessarily have to be a democratic you
could have a dictatorship that has its
own kind of laws communists have their
own kind of laws rules were ever set by
like schools yeah - well I had a really
strict like you for me palsy okay so I'm
not we're able to happen supposed to be
boring a farm school one stupid thing I
we were on to do is wear earrings a
bigger and a quarter I don't know what
that was supposed to do at all how they
fixed up - yeah but that was one stupid
is that when that happened yeah and how
would you measure whether that's a good
long rule or not you would compare it to
your what would its purposes and what it
actually accomplishes if the law tends
to just aggravate everybody it's
probably not a good law a good rule
sometimes people actually create was
just so they can have power over other
people or you know make their lives
miserable I mean that's not usually the
case thank God but it happens right some
laws are created just to enforce
inequalities you know I brought up
Martin Luther King a couple of times
this semester Martin Luther King refers
in a letter from a Birmingham jail to
Thomas Aquinas
and this notion of human laws having to
be tested the in accordance with some
sort of criteria that comes from the
natural